music to monday night football
there's a new way to get into the game i
stopped by the luminarium earlier today
to get a preview of their sports
experience check it out
at the aluminum you can immerse yourself
into space into the wild and now into
monday night football callum oh welcome
back rocky so glad to have you back here
oh my gosh as you can tell the weather's
telling us the summer season is over but
as you can see inside here football
season is just starting yeah we're
launching uh sports at the luminarium
with the classic monday night this is
such a dope concept so for anyone who
hasn't been to the illuminarium yet is
one of my favorite spots here in las
vegas you know explain what they're
experiencing when they set foot into the
room well if you remember the last time
you were here we were in the middle of
kenya yeah and it was reviewed and it
was beautiful but uh today we're in the
gridiron so the concept remains the same
it's a place that can take you any place
and right now we're putting you in the
heart of the game putting you on the
field so you get a whole different
perspective of the game now this is just
the beginning of the experience this is
the lounge so explain that so the lounge
as you can see we set up with some games
we've got jenga we've got corn hall
we've got connect four this is just a
happy place hang out you'll still be
able to see the game but this is this is
more for again just that relaxed moment
step out of the action a little before
the main the main attraction come on in
oh my gosh imagine walking into here
with your favorite football players on
the screen the sounds the lights the the
friendship i love it in here now we are
21 and over only father's day so bring a
lot of your friends we've got plenty of
comfy seating as you can see but
first come first serve so get here early
we open 30 minutes uh before kickoff we
have the full service bar and of course
what better to accompany a full-service
bar than the best food in town then
delicious classic football eat so let's
talk about what's on the menu column
right so right here we're starting off
with
bbq pulled pork sliders great for
breakfast just as much as it is for game
time exactly moving over one of my
favorites of course the classic wing
collection right now we're starting with
some hot buffalo of course we also do
medium and mild we have barbecue wings
and my favorite personal favorite is a
curry ipa source which is just to die
for everything is unique here at the
illuminarium and last but not least what
do we have so right here we have our
take on the classic jalapeno popper
these are cheese filled uh chilies
and on a special salad that's made here
and unique you're only going to find
these here at illumina look at this
presentation this is great and to go
along with this you mentioned the full
service bar
not just your regular basic drinks we of
course have all the classics from beer
right the way through your regular
cocktails but i like to say our
nightlife manager he's a bit of an
alchemist and he's been infusing uh
vodkas and tequilas over jalapenos and
berries for like three weeks up to 13
weeks to give a very unique set of
flight shots um only going to find them
here at illuminary i love it so who's
playing tonight so tonight it's the
broncos and seahawks
of course we're building up to the
classic game on october 10th between the
raiders and the chiefs
and one last mention of course is we
also have special group seating for
groups of 10 or more which is full
bottle service uh get in touch with us
at lv dash groups illuminarium.com got
it and that raiders game imagine the
raiders fans in here and i'll be one of
them i've been here 20 years now so i'm
i'm a local so i'll be cheering the
raiders on right the way
all the way oh man monday night football
here inside the illuminarium immerse
yourself
into the game
such a dope experience it's so cool in
there and you know you can party if your
team wins you can party at illuminary
map or dark after i'm a cowboys fan so
that won't happen yeah all right now
we're talking tokyo drifting the fuel
fest